so family-friendly Halloween movies are
kind of hard to come by why should
families go see this film Elissa this
pg-13 first of all so everybody over 13
you I think they're gonna really enjoy
it it's not very scary but it's really
really funny and it is for both
generations your generation axiom and
your Millennials are coming together in
this movie just this justice the cast
came together I think families would
come together and they'd enjoy it so you
get to play dress up everyday in this
movie you're dressing up as three
different characters what would your
dream Halloween costume beat you even
dress up for Halloween I don't I don't
my dream Halloween costume would be not
having to put on a costume that's what
really I'm not I'm not big on Halloween
I'm not big on witches and demons and
goblins and ghosts and things like that
I don't do that paranormal stuff I don't
even watch the movies - I'm a big scary
cat when it comes to that stuff same
here yeah same here
so if I come trick-or-treating to the
Perry house what are you giving out at
this Halloween the lights will be off
and the gate will be closed so you
wouldn't get very close all right all
right ed what about if I go to my Diaz
house yes you have some candy but you
have to watch a couple and she put a
hand down in your bag to drop a one
piece of candy she's gonna take five
pieces out of your bag trick-or-treat
Dambach